Stéphane thurillon restaurateur qui va
vendre son établissement et travaille 15
heures par jour 7 jours sur 7 et ne
gagne même pas 1000 euros par mois
bonsoir mon Stéphane que je connais bien
merci Monsieur merci
je pense que ça va bouger dans 2 minutes
monsieur je suis millionnaire vous
rendez compte c'est formidable non
millionnaire en quoi millionnaire en
euros bien sûr parce que le rouble c'est
pas c'est pas encore court ici mais
bientôt je pense aussi monsieur Véran je
suis très agacé en vérité parce que le
covid le covid a coûté cher à la France
le covid a coûté cher en restaurateur on
peut dire ce qu'on veut qu'on a été aidé
c'est une connerie sans nom je m'excuse
je suis un peu indicatif mais on
voudrait pas je contiens ma colère
je trouve que vous avez mal géré cette
crise premièrement c'est mon point de
vue le vote je sais pas du mien c'est de
la merde franchement c'est taquet j'ai
perdu 700000 euros j'ai ouvert en 2019
j'ai mis un million sur la table pour
ouvrir cet établissement ça m'a coûté
une fortune j'ai fermé décembre janvier
j'ai envie 2020 pour faire des travaux
j'ai ouvert en février le 15 mars vous
fermez j'ai été fermé 11 mois vous
m'avez donné 70 000 euros d'aide
d'accord 70 000 euros d'aide et j'avais
deux apprentis donc j'ai pas forcément
profité comme les grosses structures je
ne citerai pas qu'il y avait des
centaines d'employés qui eux ont eu le
chômage partiel on est d'accord là
dessus après il y a eu le passeport
vaccinal le vaccin obligatoire et
compagnie moi je ne suis pas vacciné
d'accord je ne le serais jamais ça c'est
une certitude aussi il a fallu trier les
clients les clients que vous m'avez
demandé de trier j'ai refusé j'avais
tellement de flics chez moi tous les
jours que maintenant je connais leur
prénom par cœur c'est pas compliqué hein
ils seront venus tous les jours tous les
jours j'ai galéré comme un fou pour
essayer de remonter ma boîte parce que
vous imaginez bien monsieur errant qu'à
un moment donné quand vous investissez
dans une nouvelle entreprise bah vous
mettez ce que vous avez puis les
économies que vous avez forcément vous
les mettez sur la table moi j'avais plus
rien
m'aider un petit peu d'aide c'est pas de
l'aide que je demandais je demandais mon
droit de travailler une chose à 25%
j'aurais même pas eu besoin de vous
aides parce que si on calcule bien dans
l'absolu à 25 millions par jour même sur
cette sur cette ça me dérangeait pas de
travailler je continue de payer mes
charges je continue de payer mes
employés je continue de vivre et donc
d'engranger la trésorerie ce qui paraît
normal on est d'accord ça vous n'avez
pas laissé faire mais pas laisser faire
mais c'est tout le monde 10000 d'accord
même le mec a pas besoin il prenait
10000 puis après les vege c'était 25% du
PGE d'accord que l'État a garanti vous
avez déposé quelque chose quelque part
en termes de garantie parce que 90000
euros pour moi Cyril ça fait 25% de mon
chiffre d'affaires de l'époque bien sûr
25% de mon chiffre d'affaires de
l'époque aujourd'hui vous avez mis sur
la table 140 milliards d'euros de
millions d'euros pardon excuse-moi un
milliard d'euros
milliards d'euros ces milliards d'euros
aujourd'hui ce sont nous les français
qui payons aujourd'hui il faut savoir
qu'il y a 49 % de faillite
supplémentaires en 2022 dans
l'hôtellerie restauration c'est PGE là
qui va les payer ça c'est ma première
question ma deuxième question c'est
quand est-ce que moi vous me remboursez
sur ma perte personnelle parce que vous
me demandez de rembourser un PGE et des
charges à ne plus savoir qu'en faire je
paye 30 % matière en plus depuis 2019
vous connaissez le prix du litre du
fioul monsieur Véran en fuel domestique
pour se chauffer
tous les chiffres
0 64 centimes 2022 1,54 je mange 8000
balles de fioul par an je suis au gaz
monsieur Véran combien je paye à votre
avis vous avez une idée de prix du gaz
vous avez une idée de ce qu'on paye et
nous artisans artisan mais [__] de
merde je suis en train de faire un
million d'euros je dégage 75 de marge
brute 42% de ma salariale il me reste
rien et quand il me reste vous me prenez
encore 25%. je vois pas mes gosses
pendant des mois parce qu'il faut que je
travaille en cuisine j'en chie comme un
veau mes employés sont là il lâche rien
merci à ma clientèle d'être là
franchement merci franchement je suis je
trouve ça aberrant qu'aujourd'hui vous
venez sans présenter d'excuse aux
Français je trouve ça lamentable
n'oubliez pas attendez n'oubliez pas ici
nous sommes les employeurs de l'État
vous travaillez pour nous parce qu'avec
mes charges attendez excusez-moi je vois
tous les jours à la télé c'est bon
laissez-moi parler 2 secondes
je vais expliquer comment donner les
choses doivent être dites parce que
toutes mes charges vous en faites quoi
toutes les chartes je paye sur les
salaires sur les infos indirects qui est
la TVA d'accord en 20 et à 10%, je donne
170000 euros de TVA par an j'ai donné
400 000 € de ma salariale brut bien sûr
vous avez un
il me reste rien vous nous prenez tout
tout le temps puis après on dirait il
faut donner le patron vaut mieux payer
vous savez combien on paye un plongeur
chez nous tu verras vous avez une idée
c'est 1500 euros nourri logé net net je
vous garantis ça c'est pour la plonge
plus les heures supplémentaires un
serveur c'est 2000 € j'habite à cuzange
un tout petit village de 70 habitants je
suis pas à Paris moi d'accord donc on
n'a pas forcément les moyens d'ailleurs
laissez-moi vous dire que Paris c'est la
capitale de la France et ça ne
représente pas toute la France nous
sommes des 1000 multibles de communes
une multitude d'artisans donc je ne
parle que sur que pour moi non Siri là
il y a plusieurs personnes
je voudrais vraiment vous dire ma colère
contre l'État aujourd'hui qui va
peut-être me mettre en faillite pourquoi
Monsieur varan parce qu'à un moment
donné j'ai travaillé d'accord après la
reprise du covid j'ai bossé on a
travaillé une super année d'ailleurs
c'est à dire fait beau c'est top je me
suis parce qu'on avait une périnée de
personnel j'ai créé une école avec Marie
Dufay en prison de Région Bourgogne
Franche-Comté le GRETA de Besançon qui
m'a super bien aidé pour qu'on mette en
place
des gens pour les remettre au boulot des
gens qui étaient sans emploi sans
formation de 18 à 60 ans donc je me suis
cassé la tête j'ai pas baissé les bras
aujourd'hui je baisse les bras quand
j'aurai vendu ou si je lis pas avant je
prendrai l'argent que j'ai géré le
dépenser ailleurs vous verrez plus pu 1
€ de ma poche je continuerai de payer il
me reste 3 ans à payer dans 3 ans je
quitte ce pays
ce que j'espère que tout le monde fera
ça parce qu'à un moment donné ce pays
attendez Nicolas Sarkozy un jour a dit
quand la France quand tu l'aimes pas tu
la quittes c'est vrai ou pas ben moi je
dis que quand la France n'aime plus ses
artisans ces artisans quitter le pays ça
c'est une vérité c'est pas dangereux si
vous aujourd'hui le cancer de ce pays
c'est pas nous nous on bosse si vous
vraiment vous aimiez la France Monsieur
Véran à tous les députés et tous les
sénateurs et tous les ministres où
travaillaient au SMIC au SMIC pas un
euro de plus comme ça vous comprendrez
ce que ces gens-là tout cela vivent
parce qu'avec 1300 balles aujourd'hui tu
veux pas et moi patron de de 25 salariés
dans la dans l'absolu moi pour vous
Stéphane ça fait 6 mois que j'ai pas
pris de salaire si moi j'ai pas pris un
salaire je vous montre mon compte
bancaire mon téléphone je vous le
montrerai sur les yeux j'ai pas un euro
[__] j'ai travaillé comme un Forza il
me reste rien alors me dites pas à me
parler pas de vos aides au niveau de
l'État par rapport à l'électricité ça
vaut rien ça vaut rien parce que
concrètement vous appeler il y a
personne au bout du fil hein d'accord si
vous êtes à 49% d'augmentation vous avez
sert à rien
tu as droit à rien si vous faites plus
d'un million de chiffre d'affaires rien
d'accord donc les aides de quoi on peut
même les charges vous savez que si vous
reportez votre PSG aujourd'hui
concrètement j'ai appelé mon banquier
parce qu'on s'entend bien c'est avec
super on s'appelle 17 je suis désolé je
peux pas je peux pas t'aider parce que
si je te reporte un petit coup de PG ne
serait-ce qu'une année vous voyez ce que
je veux dire parce que maintenant deux
ans de covid on la reporté les PG qui
devaient durer sur 6 ans maintenant il
dure que sur quatre on a commencé
enclencher les PG c'est une fortune ça
me va pour moi c'est 1800 balles par
mois en plus donc c'est 18000 euros
quasiment par an donc ça me coûte une
fortune un moment donné j'explique j'ai
pas la structure qui a 25 ans comme
marque qui est imposé depuis des années
moi il y a trois ans que j'ai acheté ce
resto mais on nous a pas laissé respirer
ni pendant le covid ni après le covid on
a le PGE sur la tête d'accord on a la
tête sous l'eau concrètement avec les
tout un flamber comment on fait pour
s'en sortir monsieur Véran comment alors
d'abord je vois que vous êtes en colère
non mais quel point je suis en colère
je l'imagine vous savez je j'en ai vu
d'autres et je vois que vous êtes en
colère et je critique pas les raisons de
votre colère et je pense que parmi ce
que vous avez dit il y a des trucs je
vous respecte monsieur vera en tant que
je suis pas sûr tu respectes
pas la fonction
de ferai jamais même empire ennemi
d'accord donc quand vous dites que je
suis le cancer de machin non c'est une
image monsieur si vous respectez les
gens ça veut dire que vous apprenez
aussi à ce qu'on je crois que depuis je
suis ici depuis le bonheur Cyril je
crois que je me défile pas derrière les
questions j'ai passé sélectionné les
gens qui viennent ici ce soir j'ai
empêché personne de venir d'ailleurs ce
soir sur ce plateau et donc je viens ici
pour qu'on puisse débattre et discuter
tranquillement donc moi je n'utiliserai
jamais la victime et j'utiliserai jamais
des injures ni merde ni et Monsieur
[Musique]
il y a plein de raisons pour lesquelles
vous avez le droit d'être en colère et
je remets pas en question ça je dis
juste pour qu'on puisse avoir une
discussion ça veut dire une discussion
c'est à deux je vous ai écouté
maintenant je vais essayer de vous
parler un peu
il y a des choses pour lesquelles vous
êtes exprimé ou je peux être d'accord
sur le poids des charges quand on ouvre
un restaurant sur le poids la masse
salariale les complexités
administratives vous pouvez vous
retrouver la tête sous l'eau je ne doute
pas une seconde que vous soyez un
bosseur que vous auriez pas de 15 mars
attention je ne doute pas une seconde
que la nuit quand vous essayez de dormir
vous pensez au compte et que ça vous
empêche de dormir etc non mais donc je
peux parfaitement contre ça et le niveau
de stress dans lequel vous êtes je peux
l'entendre d'accord ok les trucs sur
lesquels on tombera pas d'accord mais on
n'est pas là c'est pas le c'est pas pour
ça que vous m'interrogez ce soir sur la
gestion de crise covid je vous avais le
droit c'est votre votre opinion mais
vous avez le devoir de respecter la loi
et vous l'avez respecté puisque vous
avez fermé le restaurant et l'État en
retour là c'est là où je suis pas
d'accord je vois beaucoup de
restaurateurs je vais dans beaucoup de
restos dans beaucoup de barres dans
beaucoup de commerce ou en général les
gens disent ça a été compliqué mais vous
nous avez aidé vous nous avez aidé et
vous avez été là et de fait Stéphane il
y a pas beaucoup de restaurants qui ont
fermé suite à l'épisode du covid et la
fermeture imposée pour des raisons
sanitaires il faut ce que vous dites
regardez les chiffres alumi mais en fait
c'est en fait j'ai rencontré j'ai
rencontré d'abord j'ai rencontré Thierry
Marx le nouveau patron de lui il y a
trois semaines vous voyez donc on a
discuté ensemble on a fait le point sur
le nombre de restaurants avant la crise
après la crise et les difficultés la
grosse difficulté qui aujourd'hui que
doivent affronter aujourd'hui les
restaurateurs vous l'avez un peu dit et
vous avez une solution qui montre que
vous êtes débrouillard c'est la capacité
à recruter c'est trouver du personnel
vous l'avez dit vous-même vous avez
augmenté sans doute le salaire de votre
plongeur vous avez augmenté les salaires
de votre serveur moi la personne et
alors les serveurs ils vous diront
qu'ils ont pas le choix que de demander
une hausse de salaire parce que c'est
compliqué pour eux parce que ils sont
obligés de faire du travail haché qui
partent très tard c'est leur coûte cher
en transport etc donc de fait le marché
a évolué et on a besoin aussi d'adapter
la formation des jeunes vers les métiers
pour lesquels on peut recruter et il se
trouve que la restauration c'est de fait
un vrai métier en gros tension et que
c'est la galère pour les restaurateurs
vous le savez vous avez ça je trouve ça
très bien vous avez manifestement créé
avec la région vous avez cité Marie
guide Dufay une école de formation pour
pouvoir former vos d'autres jeunes qui
pourront ensuite travailler dans vos
restaurants et les autres restaurants de
la région ce qui est très bien 250 000
postes en hôtellerie restauration
aujourd'hui
c'est aussi pour ça que les salaires
augmentent pour ça aussi que vos charges
augmentés c'est que aujourd'hui
on paye plus un serveur au SMIC il faut
en général augmenter le salaire surtout
quand on est dans des territoires ruraux
c'est difficile de trouver des jeunes
qui peuvent venir bosser dans la
restauration de fait et donc on veut
aussi accompagner à la fois en formant
davantage de gens pour aller dans les
métiers en tension et à la fois
continuer d'accompagner les commerçants
les restaurateurs pour que ça leur il ne
soit pas obligé de mettre la clé sous la
porte parce qu'ils ont pas de personnel
ou parce que ça leur coûte trop cher ok
là dessus bon
je m'attends pas à ce que vous disiez ah
ok à la fin de notre conversation
je comprends votre problème j'ai pas dit
que j'irai un état c'est facile
j'entends vous avez un métier difficile
sûrement d'accord
sachez que dans l'absolu aujourd'hui si
on vous sait je parle vraiment de des
charges les charges inhérentes à mon
entreprise d'accord concrètement
aujourd'hui 95 % de ce que j'ai gagné
dépensé pour faire vivre l'entreprise et
si demain excusez-moi si demain je
repoussais mon PGE vous savez ce qu'on
ferait on mettrait en redressement
judiciaire alors Stéphane alors ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure je le redis ça
veut dire que du côté de Bercy aussi
lorsqu'il y a des situations
particulières que rencontre certains
restaurants l'écran de majorité les
rembourse aujourd'hui les pêche mais si
vous rencontrez des difficultés quel que
soit l'origine de ces difficultés il y a
des guichets il y a un guichet unique
vous pouvez aller appeler le préfet de
votre département ou la préfecture il y
a un interlocuteur que Bercy a désigné
pour répondre à toutes les problèmes que
peuvent rencontrer les restaurateurs les
artisans les boulangers je le disais
tout à l'heure pour voir quelle est la
source du problème et si on peut vous
accompagner dans l'absoluce que vous
comprenez pas on explique que le PG est
compliqué va être compliqué je rembourse
pour l'instant alors je dis que le PGE
va être compliqué à rembourser pourquoi
parce que vous venez de me gratter 30%
de matière supplémentaires 50 %
d'énergie en plus c'est Monsieur
ce que j'avais en tête de gains alors
Stéphane je gratte en fait alors c'est
pas moi qui fait le prix du beurre et
qui fait le prix de la viande et du
poisson voilà pardon vous êtes vous êtes
un commerçant indépendant d'accord vous
n'êtes pas fonctionnaire d'État donc ça
veut dire que on ne vous fournit pas la
matière première
qui est en cause
hier vous payez le kilo de beurre d'une
bêtise 5 euros aujourd'hui pas ça 10
euros le kilo la TVA elle augmente aussi
on est d'accord
c'est pas la TVA qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
ça vous coûte le plus cher ce qui fait
que ça coûte le prix des produits
augmenter dites pas qu'on vous gratte
sur les matières premières ce n'est pas
vrai moi je ne vous vends pas l'état ne
vous vend pas les matières premières que
vous achetez pour les transformer vous
êtes restaurateur vous achetez des
matières premières sans doute de qualité
vous les transformez et vous les vendez
en essayant de dégager une marge sur les
prix que vous appliquez ensuite aux
clients donc vous payer la marche le mec
qui gagne 1300 voitures
vous n'êtes pas à la vente x 25 on a
parlé tout à l'heure on a parlé tout à
l'heure de l'inflation et je ne nie pas
une seconde d'ailleurs les enquêtes le
monde il y a 8 Français sur 10 qui à
cause d'un inflation renonce à des
loisirs et il y en a quasiment autant
qui ont changé leur panier de course
donc on est d'accord j'ai perdu les
clients on est parfaitement l'inflation
je ne sais pas comment fonctionne votre
restaurant je sais que l'année 2022 a
été plutôt une excellente année dans le
domaine de la restauration c'est une
excellente pas une bonne et qui a plutôt
une augmentation de l'activité en 2022
je ne doute pas une seconde que le
l'impact de l'inflation se fera
ressentir aussi dans les commerces et
les restaurants comme le vôtre je ne
doute pas une seconde de ça parce que de
fait les Français sont obligés de
renoncer à des choses c'est pour ça
qu'on les accompagné
je vois que vous vous savez très bien
parler que vous plaisez aux Français
vous êtes quelqu'un de très agréable un
discourir il y a pas de souci je dis
juste qu'à un moment donné
on parle du gouvernement qui avait un
certain pouvoir avec Bercy monsieur
Macron le président de la République
aujourd'hui comprenez s'il n'y a pas
d'artisans il n'y a pas de cotisation
quand il n'y aura pas de cotisation
qu'il n'y aura défaite ou ferez quoi
avec les 140 milliards Stéphane en 2022
en 2022 il y a un million d'entreprises
qui ont été créées dans notre pays
c'est-à-dire que ça veut dire qu'il y a
une activité de création d'entreprise et
on veut la pousser ensuite vous parlez
des impôts sur les sociétés je termine
juste là-dessus parler des impôts sur
les sociétés on est plutôt en train de
nous reprocher si vous voulez plutôt à
gauche de l'hémicycle on est en train de
reprocher de supprimer une un impôt de
production sur les sur les sur le sur le
privé qui s'appelle la CVE parce qu'on
continue de supprimer des lignes
d'impôts sur les entreprises pour
qu'elles puissent justement retrouver un
petit peu d'oxygène mieux payer les gens
pour augmenter les salaires et faire de
la marge pour pour continuer donc
accompagner nos clients en ce moment
pour un million d'euros monsieur verrons
ça dépend du type de commerce oui
d'accord ça dépend du e-commerce nous
Stéphane vous dites qu'on augmente les
charges et les impôts je vous dis juste
factuellement on est plutôt tendance et
cette factuel a baissé les impôts
sur les les grosses sociétés excusez-moi
monsieur vraiment mais pour le luxe par
exemple ils ont deux taux de TVA
différents
la TVA elle était baissé c'était pas
nous c'est tout ça Sarkozy elle est
passée de 20 à 5,5 supplémentaires on
les paye taquet comme d'habitude la TVA
n'a pas changé je paye toujours autant
la TVA il y a une dizaine d'années de
combien elle est passée de 20 à 20 ans
je suis désolé elle est à combien votre
TVA aujourd'hui on a une TV à 20 sur
tout ce qui est alcool et vins est
compris spiritueux je viens manger chez
vous la ligne TVA sur le bas de la note
c'est combien alors en moyenne ça
représente ça dépend en moyenne d'un
chiffre entre 1 et 10 % 10 % pour le
solide tout ce qui est matière et
organique enfin les repas les truites le
poulet et puis vous achetez vous vendez
sur les produits comme moi je suis
client je viens de votre restaurant la
ligne de TVA La TVA elle est à combien
elle a baissé ses Sarkozy qu'il avait
baissé ah non c'est faux mais vous
n'êtes pas sûr vous êtes allé au
restaurant
on n'est pas sur une TVA emporter je
suis pas un kebab enfin je suis un
restaurant je fais des trucs à 20 % de
TVA sur les produits à 10 %, je fais pas
du 5 10 % 20 sur les alcools tout ce qui
est vin et 10 % sur le reste ça s'arrête
là donc la baissé votre TVA elle était à
20 % sur tout mais vous rigolez ou pas
nous avons fait on l'a jamais été je
suis désolé elle a eu baissé
à 5 5 à 10 %
Sarkozy et après ça fait un tollé au
niveau de l'État les gens étaient pas
oui on se souvient pas de la même chose
c'est bien ce que je dis donc un moment
donné elle est remontée à 10 c'est pour
les alcools à 20% c'est-à-dire qu'à un
moment donné aujourd'hui en terme de TVA
on se fait explosé en termes de charges
on s'est explosé en termes de matière on
s'est explosé en termes d'énergie on se
fait exposé on s'est explosé partout
je veux bien j'entends ce que vous dites
je dirais juste comprenez-moi on a un
million de chiffre d'affaires comprenez
c'est important 75 de marge brut 42 %
dans scénario c'est la moyenne nationale
hein Marc on doit être
au dessus je suis 7 points de plus
au-dessus on fait une super année vous
voyez c'est génial merci
et moi je prends pas de salaire je vois
pas mes gosses et en plus tu travailles
combien de temps grosso modo je me lève
le matin quand je fais pas les courses
je me lève il est 7h le temps de boire
un petit café de me mettre en route je
finis les 15h je reprends à 17 puis je
finis les minuit voilà et ça c'est
évidemment six jours sur 7 ben moi je
suis le patron donc tu sais les papiers
il faut bien les faire
effectivement
et puis tout ce qui est école et
compagnie voilà tu te dans la réalité et
vous comprenez comment on est ok je suis
en colère mais je veux qu'on me trouve
une solution et qu'on dise un jour mais
que ce soit les boulangeries que ce soit
n'importe qui
vous allez pas regarder tous vos
connexions
et c'est pour ça honnêtement qu'on a
engagé beaucoup d'argent public pour
éviter au commerçants de mourir et je
vous redonne les chiffres de restaurants
sont pas en train de fermer les
restaurants ont tenu malgré la crise
covid Stéphane c'est factuel vous pouvez
regarder je vais regarder
je vous redis le problème numéro 1
aujourd'hui c'est la capacité de
recruter vous l'avez dit parmi juste un
point j'ai dit une bêtise donc je
corrige mes propres bêtises vous avez
raison elle est descendue à 5 5 sur les
clients elle est remontée à 10 derrière
donc j'ai dit une bêtises n'empêche
qu'elle était avant avant donc elle est
plutôt mais c'est pardon donc on a pas
augmenté vos charges et vos impôts juste
pour juste un moment donné sur ces
produits là vous comprenez que les
produits de première nécessité que ça
soit le beurre la farine et compagnie
regardez les boulangers aujourd'hui
la margarine la crème fraîche + 17 %
l'avion dès le poisson plus 30%. voilà
alors on peut dire que c'est les
matières de nutrition pour les animaux
je suis d'accord avec vous moi j'ai lève
détruite donc ça se passe bien mais dans
l'absolu tout monte et la problématique
c'est qu'à un moment donné nous sommes
alors moi j'achète toutes les matières
que vous me dites elles sont très belles
on achète des viandes de chez nous du
fromage de chez nous du bon comté du bon
beurre de passage et le problème c'est
que le mec qui vient manger madame
monsieur
tu comprends les retraités ils ont mis
le bal il arrive il voit le menu moi je
fais un nu je fais mon coeur
aujourd'hui
donc aujourd'hui si lui demain il ferme
son restaurant
s'il a pas d'argent de côté il se
retrouve c'est cuit pour une
statuts tout ça donc tu penses quitter
la France et c'est vrai que aujourd'hui
il y a beaucoup de gens qui nous
regardent monsieur le ministre est-ce
qu'il est pas possible de
d'alléger un peu tout ça parce que c'est
vrai que
Cyril encore une fois depuis 5 ans on a
baissé les impôts des Français à hauteur
de 26 milliards d'euros c'est à dire que
c'est la ça fait très longtemps que les
impôts avaient pas baissé et on a baissé
on a baissé les charges les cotisations
patronales on a baissé les charges et on
baisse et personne ne dit qu'on a
suffisamment baissé les abos je dis
juste qu'on est dans un mouvement après
des années
32,7% sur certaines cotisations donc
vous dites que vous baissez
on supprime des impôts on supprime des
lignes d'impôts je suis prêt à ce qu'on
regarde ensemble ce que vous avez le
niveau de charge et de taxes qui ce qui
vous auriez payé il y a 5 ans est-ce que
vous payez aujourd'hui je suis prêt ça
veut pas dire qu'on a supprimé
suffisamment d'impôts c'est à dire qu'il
faut plutôt nous accompagner parce que
là vous voyez sur le débat actuellement
au Parlement là sur la réforme des
retraites vous avez tout un tas de
responsables politiques qui sont pas
dans notre majorité et qui considèrent
qu'ils font qu'on augmente les
cotisations patronales sur les retraites
donc moi je vous invite juste non mais
parce que mais ce sera la faillite
vous aurez des questions
c'est que nous on fait justement le
choix pour équilibrer les retraites de
ne pas augmenter les cotisations
patronales alors qu'on nous reproche à
gauche de l'hébicycle de ne pas le faire
et j'assume qu'on ne fasse pas je verrai
je fais pas de politique avec vous
monsieur Véran je suis en train de vous
parler d'un projet on est plutôt
d'accord d'un artisan en France qui vous
explique je pense que ça ressemble à
beaucoup partout comme ça en France et
aujourd'hui concrètement j'ai pas de en
fait
je me permettrais pas de le faire et je
connais pas votre je j'imagine votre
quotidien sans le connaître et j'ai
jamais été restaurateur j'ai eu des
restaurateurs j'ai eu des restaurateurs
dans ma famille et j'ai vu la difficulté
que c'était et j'ai vu comment est-ce
que ça se terminait parfois hélas quand
ça se finissait mal donc je ne
reconnaître la difficulté de votre et le
sentiment de de rochers de saisie tous
les matins quand vous voyez ce qui vous
tombe sur le crâne en terme de tâches
administratives de charge je vous dis
juste que la trajectoire qui la nôtre
c'est plutôt de réduire des lignes sur
vos feuilles qu'est-ce qu'on fait c'est
ça monsieur
vous en famille pour une très grande
occasion il y a quelques années au
verrier du lac je pensais que vous étiez
quelqu'un de bien et de connaisseur
j'étais pas très vieux mais je me
souviens d'un espèce de dessert fumant
c'était le repas alors je crois que
c'était vraiment on m'a parlé
j'aurais détendre l'atmosphère ah c'est
bien vous avez le même chapeau
l'atmosphère parce que c'est bien vous
savez je vais vous dire c'est le
ministre
comme les précédents vous savez ce que
c'est le problème le fond du problème
c'est que ces gens-là sont
en état d'échecs
des proportions invraisemblables dû à
tout ce qui leur arrive aux charges mais
ce sont avant tout des amoureux de leur
métier exactement je crois qu'on ne l'a
pas assez vu on ne l'a pas séduit et ça
il faut les applaudir aucun doute
je veux dire aucun doute je vous dis
on se décharge à la décharge de mon ami
il vous a heurté je le comprends très
bien
ne pensez pas du tout que vous étiez le
cancer c'est pas vrai voilà alors
pardonner là et après on continue alors
là moi je voulais vous dire une chose
il y a une chose qui me fascine moi
quand même depuis le début
on va se parler franchement monsieur le
ministre allez-y allez
non mais moi je vous aime bien donc on
va se parler franchement
c'est pendant le covid vous êtes chez
ministre de la Santé bon c'était
géométrie variable il s'est passé des
choses mais vous avez bien géré
le problème
et j'ai comme l'impression que
aujourd'hui
c'est un état de fête qui arrive avec
cette loi sur la retraite mais pourquoi
on me dit qu'on est en excédent sur le
ministre c'est vrai ou pas pourquoi
est-ce que ça arrive maintenant tous les
gens qui vous ont parlé avant de parler
de retraite
mais vous avez vu comment ils sont ils
sont heurtés ces gens ils n'en parlaient
que de leur profession que de leur
désespérance on aurait pas pu attendre
un an un an et demi de plus et aller
confronter tout ce qui nous arrive
aujourd'hui avec exactementations assez
récente avec ces prises de position sur
les sociétés c'est ça le fond du
problème c'est ça et puis une chose que
je voulais vous dire vraiment je vous en
prie faites une loi pour ces seniors
que l'on Médor des entreprises à 50 53
ans c'est ignoble c'est la structure
même de la société confond en l'air
c'est la transmission auprès des jeunes
il faut les sauver ces gens-là il faut
qu'il revienne on a besoin d'eux alors
je vous écoutais avec le talent à toi
quel vôtre
chapeau Baba
c'est quelqu'un de formidable formidable
on a non mais c'est vrai tu donnes
l'ouverture à tout le monde le droit de
parole mais vous l'avez pas passé
aromatique la soirée elle a pas été
aromatique pour vous répondre
j'essaie de me concentrer ça fait
pas y arriver non vous dire d'abord vous
êtes l'un des grands de la gastronomie
française et soyez salués pour ça bon
une fois que j'ai dit ça excellent une
année
parce que il y a eu une baisse du
chômage parce qu'on a créé plus
d'emplois que prévu et c'est tant mieux
par contre les maths ils sont ce qu'ils
sont en fait et les chiffres sont têtus
et nous montrent que
vous êtes retraités maintenant je crois
que vous avez laissé le restaurant à
votre fille vous n'êtes pas resté
par le silence
je croyais que c'est votre fille mais
peut-être que vous avez gardé un resto
pardon pour ça non non on va prendre
l'exemple on va prendre l'exemple de
Josiane pardon Josiane je remets un
contribution
Josiane quand elle travaillait elle
cotisait sur chacune de ses feuilles de
paye pour la retraite de personnes qui
sont peut-être aujourd'hui plus de ce
monde ou qui sont très âgés
à l'époque Josiane elle cotisait pour
elles étaient il y avait trois Josiane
qui cotisaient pour un retraité
et depuis la population vieillit c'est
formidable on a gagné des années des
décennies d'espérance de vie on vit plus
longtemps plus longtemps en bonne santé
etc et bien en plus il y a
vieillissement de la population l'impact
du pépite du papy boom et compagnie et
maintenant des Josiane ensuite il y a
quelques années des Josiane qui
cotisaient pour un retraité c'était
deux puis maintenant c'est 1,7 et puis
dans pas longtemps ça va être 1,5 puis
1,4 donc les calculs sont pas bons comme
dirait l'autre ça veut dire que à la fin
des seins il y a plus assez de d'actifs
par rapport au nombre de retraités et
donc là ça crée un déséquilibre ça a un
trou qui va passer à 10 milliards par an
puis ensuite à 15 milliards par an 20
milliards par an etc donc c'est le
fameux déséquilibre des retraites qu'on
a déjà vécu par le passé qui avait
nécessité d'autres réformes et nous on
fait on prend le parti de se dire il
vaut mieux travailler un peu plus
longtemps qu'augmenter les impôts
augmenter la dette je l'ai déjà dit tout
à l'heure
alors il y a pas il y a jamais de bons
moments en fait politiquement pour
réformer des retraites et je vous prends
le pari que si on disait
qu'on le fait dans un an ou dans deux
ans je suis à peu près sûr qu'on me
dirait la même chose c'est pas le bon
moment moi il y a bien un truc que je
veux concéder
c'est que il faut qu'on renforce notre
message à destination notamment des plus
jeunes sur l'évolution du rapport au
travail ce que c'est que le travail dans
la vie d'un homme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure à fade de plus en plus les gens
quand ils rentrent dans un métier c'est
pas pour l'exercer pendant 40 ans c'est
pour changer tous les cinq six ans il
faut de la rotation et donc ça il faut
qu'on l'accompagne ensuite on en a parlé
tout à l'heure avec Stéphane rapidos
mais dans les difficultés de recrutement
dans les métiers de la restauration il y
a aussi l'envie de concilier davantage
la vie personnelle la vie familiale et
la vie professionnelle et donc le jeune
qui vient et qui dit je vais faire le
jeudi le vendredi le samedi le dimanche
soir je vais venir le midi et puis je
vais rentrer 2h chez moi je verrai pas
mes gosses c'est terminé c'est terminé
et vous avez aussi une France une France
ouvrière qui elle n'a pas accès au
télétravail et donc il continue d'aller
au boulot de chez trempe
bien sûr la restauration vous avez pas
télétravail
30 40 50 km pour aller au boulot ça
prend du temps ça coûte cher les gens ne
veulent plus ça non plus ils veulent
travailler moins loin de chez eux ou
limiter les déplacements donc ils
veulent du télétravail ils peuvent pas
la voir donc il faut sans doute aussi
les accompagner dans leur volonté de
réorganiser leur temps de travail dans
la semaine pour moi la semaine des
quatre jours c'est pas un gros mot si il
y a 35 heures qui sont organisés
différemment et je pense que ce 1 on a
parfaitement conscience de ça de ces
évolutions du rapport au travail deux on
le dit peut-être pas suffisamment et en
gros il y a des assises par exemple
National du Travail qui ont été ouvertes
à la demande des syndicats depuis le
mois de décembre j'avoue que même moi si
j'étais pas porte-parole je saurais pas
au courant donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'on insiste davantage et qu'on
accompagne les changements les mutations
dans le monde du travail mon message en
gros c'est une phrase c'est pas la
réforme des retraites pour seul de tout
compte c'est la réforme des retraites le
plein emploi la formation
professionnelle et on accompagne les
changements du rapport au travail et là
on y arrivera mais vous avez raison
monsieur le ministre mais vous savez
c'est un problème générationnel
aujourd'hui
il faut être ouvert d'esprit
vous savez hier hier c'était hier
la référence c'était quoi c'était
le guide Michelin souvenez-vous bien sûr
oh le guide Michelin c'est
extraordinaire c'est fini il n'en
veulent plus ils ne veulent plus
d'étoiles ils veulent être libre ils
veulent travailler en totale liberté
vous comprenez ils veulent plus de
contraintes ils ne veulent plus de tout
ça et peut-être qu'ils ont raison parce
que vous savez certains ils veulent
travailler
ils veulent travailler ils veulent
travailler notre condition et ces
histoires de guide cette histoire de
guide de harcèlement perpétuel ce n'est
pas normal imagine imaginez-vous ben ben
quelqu'un qui est dans la salle et qui
vous note en toute discrétion
il faut que tu viennes chez moi tu
verras
et on a une voûte céleste extraordinaire
on a plein d'étoiles et Lucien est plus
belles étoiles c'est ce qu'ils ont
raconté tous c'est les étoiles que
possèdent les clients dans leurs yeux le
reste on s'en fout voilà merci
[Applaudissements]